this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction people citizens of the reject
Nation it is time to watch the trailer
dose for easily the most anticipated
comic book movie of the year sure to be
box office Behemoth number 20 Aquaman
and the lost kingdom John how are you
I'm good G how are you doing well this
is Jason mimos confirmed himself on the
tonight show his last time he's going to
be playing Aquaman who knows what else
he's going to be doing in the DC
Universe afterwards no one has a clue
anywh who guys leave a like on this
video let's see what's going on in this
trailer hi baby boy talking to the
fishies you and me we're different that
aqu we're connected to the land and the
sea I can't wait to introduce you to all
the Majestic creatur our planet look at
him an or just kicking this will can
be yeah you and
me whoa where's his wife I'm going to
kill
Aquaman damn even if I have to make a
deal with the devil to do
it free me from my prison there's that
James one I'd like will be yours the key
to this prison is the Royal bloodline
itself because here they are he needs us
we're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're not uhoh he's your
kid oh
no I bet his mom's going to be upset
about that
J he must be
stopped oh they're going to totally
kill that kid he's got your baby I'm
coming for
you
destroy everything he holds
de you want
bloody come get it damn he does some
really intense in this one oh aquam and
the lost kingdom oh dude we got to
go for Christmas day in the theaters on
Christmas for Aquaman too I'm not going
to lie I actually like that trailer more
than the last one yeah that was my first
thought was this actually looks like a
really cool
movie oh man yeah oh wait wait wait who
hold on you know I just was thinking the
fact that we are using the internet
right now to watch this trailer someone
might be trying to get our secrets
so big thanks to express vpm for
sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about expressvpn for online
privacy and security but there's more to
it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing down my internet and contacting me
due to a suspecting hacking attemp and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
cinema at your fingertips it's super
easy open Express VPN switch refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix
Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you again I actually thought that
trailer zeroed in a lot more on a lot
more personal intensity you know the
setup of like I really love my my baby
I'm not a single dad but for some
reason pretend like what happened she
can't afford to come on the L to this
one even though she spent the first one
on l i I don't know why Warner Brothers
would be hiding the wife at all makes no
sense to me what's going on I'm sure the
comments are not at all talking about
that the visuals they actually even
though the trailer is shorter the the
the visuals actually popped a lot better
to me you got more of that dark
aesthetic I like some of that like icy
stuff that we were seeing seems like the
baby going to die or the dad no be the
baby cuz he's talking about looking for
the last um The Last Of The Bloodline
the last of the bloodline be his baby
and in the last half of this trailer he
just seems like freaking Furious yeah
man he's got to fight for his progyny
we're going to see a dead baby in this
room this is going to be it's going to
end darkest note that zoom out from the
ocean one BS to the surface and then we
zoom out to reveal that it's just all
babies just all over the surface of the
sea jeez it's going to be James ju's
dead baby movie well I mean I thought I
thought Manta was in the F in the
trailer for the first one like w Yaya is
like I think one of the best actors
around right now it just kind of felt
repetitive of the last one but the the
the Menace portrayed even though Again
trailer being shorter I felt it more
everything was just more about a feeling
and while and it seemed like it did
expand in the the locations of what we
saw seemed like we are going to some
darker
terrain it does seem like we are going
to some darker terrain here and not just
physic physically but emotionally for
our characters this time so I I did feel
like unlike the last trailer I did get
something different here that did Feel
Again more personal yeah yeah yeah it's
weird I I think this was a great choice
to to compact should have been the first
trailer it really should have because
now we know I mean like the first
trailer gives us the sense that like orm
and and uh you know Arthur Arthur are
going to bond and they're going to go on
this adventure together and they're
going to do some Indiana Jones stuff and
like you could have done that here like
you know that isn't very apparent from
this but yeah just the idea that like
he's got his son uh it's very dear at
the beginning I love that whole thing
where he's talking about like oh soon
all the you know Simba someday all this
going to be yours uh and and then to do
the flip instead of Mufasa dying Simba
exactly and then him and Scar got to
team up that's right 100% they got to go
take on uh hyena
or whoever else fits the lion kinging
metaphor but yeah like it's a personal
seter got to go get Bob IG for him to
worry about uh yeah and then this is a
very Universal motivation for why the
adventure will start but we know that
the adventure is going to have all the
dazzling crazy visuals that we've come
to expect from Aquaman and I liked that
you do still have you know these what
looks to be you know like trench
dwellers and stuff that can at least
alleviate the pain of losing the trench
movie yeah and you've got that guy who
comes up the the the first guy they talk
to who I don't know exactly what his
character is but he looks like the dun
Harrow king or something he looks like
the the king of the Dead Army and the
Lord of the Rings and even the way he
moves kind of had this like stop motion
esque flavor to it so I'm excited to see
what kind of like Ray Harry how and
tributing they do with those characters
um yeah CU it seems like they're they're
leaning more into the fantasy side of it
where in the first movie because there's
like oh we have the rules of the world
and there's like uh the Sci-Fi element
of atlantans that are atlantans
atlantans Atlant which there's no T at
the at it is atlantans not atlantans
okay so it's they have the
atlanteans are we sure about that in
America we just dull out the te so I
think either one is acceptable I didn't
bring attention to it I think people are
either saying atlans or atlantans
basically so atlantans is fine all right
okay so with the Atlantis kind of folks
that in the last movie like while they
did have some of that Fantastical lore
that they lean into is more of the rules
of we have atlantans who live underwater
they breathe underwater and stuff but in
terms of the
mysticism of Destiny and and and more
that Lord of the Rings type of fantasy s
quality that to to lean into that I
think is probably a smarter call to do
this time around yeah or or just pee on
it yeah just pee on it um guys what did
you think about this trailer did do you
like it is the dialogue working for you
sure it's just as cheesy as always what
are you going to do I mean it's the
first it's a sequel to the first one but
I I like this one this one actually I
thought it was a much better trailer
yeah I was surprised by it and they took
out the one shot of Amber herd so that
we would all forget that che's even we
forgot I'm sure the comments are not
talking all about it nope never all
right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below thank you to expressvpn for
sponsoring and we will catch you all
very very
[Music]
soon